[Music]
mate do you remember when Banks were
amoral Psychopathic institutions that
only cared about money the days when
they gleefully hand out a 100 mortgage
to an unemployed mother of seven with
three teeth and a face tattoo whilst
also laundering Millions from Mexican
drug cartels we didn't know it at the
time but those were the Glory Days of
banking now they've developed a social
conscience and it is dystopian as hell
like us at trigonometry Nigel farage has
had his account with Coots Bank closed
for what they initially claimed were
unspecified commercial reasons following
a freedom of information request we now
know the real reason was because Nigel
farage's views did not align with their
values would you like to know whose
values do align with Coots Bank Chilean
dictator General
Emilio de giovini an Egyptian leader I'm
not going to do the accent Hosni Mubarak
have all had bank accounts with them
General Pinochet was a brutal dictator
who was responsible for The
Disappearance of 3 000 people terrible
yes but nowhere near as bad as brexit
how many people died due to brexit
Millions
allegedly we all know that brexit
started the pandemic and it was
single-handedly responsible for 9 11.
you probably didn't know this but
there's nothing Osama Bin Laden hated
more than the single Market say what you
like about dictators and Matthew Dons
but none of them have ever forced me to
use a slightly longer Queue at the
airport yes Matthew boss Emilio
digiovanni spent most of his life in
prison for violent gang crime but has he
ever stopped you from getting a bar job
in Benidorm no brexit is a crime against
humanity some would argue against nature
itself we must not stop at bank accounts
let's cut off farage's water supply the
only way to get Britain back into the EU
is to stop Nigel flushing his toilet and
whilst we're at it why not turn off his
gas as well let's force him to live in a
medieval hovel with no heating or
running water it's only when he's doomed
to living the life of a 13 Century surf
will he understand how pissed off we are
having to leave the Customs Union coach
chief executive Dame Allison Rose has
apologized we choose great news I'm
confident strong and Swift action will
be taken just like after the crash in
2008 we all want Banks to be the more
Arbiters of society who wouldn't seek
guidance from a cocaine adult sociopath
whose only purpose in life is to make
enough money to buy their soul back from
the devil these are the people you want
deciding what is and isn't acceptable
every time I see a banker stumbling out
of a strip club at 6am sniffing
they always remind me of Jesus if Jesus
was alive today he'd be a banker with a
platinum encounter magnificent others
Gentleman's Club every single person in
the UK will be sweating at the thought
of having their bank account closed not
prince Andrew because it's your
political opinions that matter not your
actions
foreign
[Music]